-I'm always so flattered
and honored
when people who are currently
doing a Broadway show
come to this show because
you really only have
the one day off a week,
and yet, you have chosen
to spend your Monday here.
-Yeah, I think to be
on Broadway,
you just have to give up
having any days off.
-Yeah.
-Just forget it.
-Has it been daunting?
Because obviously you've done
film and television.
Not only is the work
so different,
but the schedule
is so different.
-I think that being, you know,
the lead of a Broadway play
is hands down the hardest job
in show business.
-I believe it.
-But incredibly satisfying.
-You are -- the show,
you play a socialite in D.C.,
this is a very topical show,
who is trying to get her husband
a job as a judge in the Trump
administration via blackmail.
-Yes. Via blackmail.
-Yeah.
-Of course.
-Of course. Why not?
-What else are you going to use?
-Guys, there's maybe
some shady stuff happening
in D.C.
-The egalitarian system,
we're done with it.
We're just pure nepotism,
pure blackmail.
-So -- but you and I have
something similar,
which is, we obviously, are both
talking about the world
in our jobs.
So it's not really escapism.
Are you finding --
is it cathartic to talk about
Trump or is it --
do you find it overwhelming?
-Well, huh, I would say
overwhelming as an American.
-Yeah.
-And as a patriot.
-But as an artist,
it's a lot of fun.
But, no, it's --
I was involved with a play
when it was written about
a Washington couple and sort of
the bedroom mischief,
she's very naughty,
liberated woman that I play,
but then Trump was elected while
we were developing the play,
so naturally, the world changed
and it became this --
it's kind of like one person
described it as like
a rock concert almost,
because the audience
is getting such a sort of,
like, a relief of laughter
and sort of bitter irony
and they kind of let loose.
-You do have something that's --
-Like they do here.
-Yeah, exactly.
Something that's very risky,
though, because plays,
we can change based on the news
every day what we write.
-Right.
-You guys have a play that's
written, John Kelly is mentioned
a lot in the show.
-14 times.
-Oh, yeah. I just had a count
done just a couple weeks ago.
[ Laughs ]
-But 14 times a day,
I feel as though we hear rumors
that he's about to be fired.
-It's true.
-What would happen --
-Or possibly say
enough is enough.
-Or leave. Exactly.
We should give him the power
to make his own choices, yeah.
-I mean, definitely.
-Have you guys discussed what
would happen if that changed?
-There was some e-mails went
around the last few weeks
where I was kind of like,
contingency plan, please,
because the play
will have to pivot.
Yeah, absolutely.
-I wrote a lengthy play
about Anthony Scaramucci.
-And it just didn't work out.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, Beau Willimon
said to me when we were in --
before rehearsal, he was like,
"I was really looking forward
to making you say Scaramucci,
Scaramucci, Scaramucci."
-Yeah, Scaramucci
is far more fun to say.
-Just turned into Kelly.
-So, I wanted to ask about this,
you grew up -- you had
a very interesting upbringing.
And now I have a 2-year-old
and we spend a lot of time,
my wife and I, talking about
the things you talk about
in front of your child,
intelligent conversations.
Your father
was a Buddhist scholar.
So did you -- was the
conversation around
your dinner table growing up,
was it incredibly, like,
not just enlightened,
but intellectually superior
to the point --
-It was usually, like,
eat your dinner!
[ Laughs ]
-That does not seem in line
with Buddhists.
-Have your vegetables!
-Yeah.
-No, but well, you know,
growing up in an academic
environment can be challenging.
It's good for you to be prepared
for the hard-hitting brains
of Hollywood.
[ Laughter ]
But, You Know --
-Yeah.
-All that hard work.
[ Applause ]
But, no, it was good.
Good debate skills.
-Uh-huh.
-I think my dad had been, like,
captain of the debate team
when he went to school.
-I think that's very helpful.
I think arguing is the one skill
that's helpful --
-Follow the ball.
-Yeah,
it's helpful in all fields.
-Thinking in general, actually.
-Thinking in general is helpful,
yeah.
Now, did you have, like,
sort of escapism things
that you liked as a kid?
-I went to Hollywood.
-There you go.
You got to meet --
-I escaped all the way.
-You got to meet
another scholar backstage.
And this is a really exciting --
-Yes, a woman whom I love.
-A woman you love.
There's Dr. Ruth.
-Dr. Ruth. Best time ever.
Not our first meeting, though.
-I got to be honest,
I had thought you were taller
than her.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you know, she grew.
She grew.
-Yeah, she's a very --
how was that?
I mean, that must be one
of the fun things to do
in your Broadway show, is
the people who come backstage.
-Yes, really great
seeing great people
including, like, distant family,
relatives, like,
that you wouldn't have met that,
like, come and see your play.
-Oh, they're just lying
to get backstage.
-Hi, I'm your cousin.
No, it's been on a family level
actually,
it's been really fun.
-That's great.
-Yeah, I've gotten to meet
some relatives from down South
that I never grew up with.
But Dr. Ruth is a gem.
My character is so sexually
promiscuous and naughty.
She really appreciated her.
-Oh, that's good.
[ Laughter ]
Did she have any notes
or did it all ring true
to Dr. Ruth?
-She thought it was --
I was doing well with it.
-That's great. Well, that's
the highest praise you can get.
-That really was good.
-Hey, congratulations
so much on the show.
-Thank you.
-I also want to say you had
a wonderful piece
in "The New York Times"
about your experiences
with Harvey Weinstein
on the set of "Kill Bill."
I, you know, I think it's
been so wonderful how people
are speaking out about
their experiences in this moment
we're having right now.
And I just wanted to thank you
for doing that, as well.
-Well, you got to be a citizen.
You can't leave people alone
holding a bag of truth
by themselves.
-That's very -- I'm glad --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But there's no one I wish
to get due process
more than him.
-Yeah. Well, due process
is a beautiful thing.
Thank you so much for
being here. Such a pleasure.